[Musique]
puisque nous étudions l'origine
de l'homme n'est pas clair cependant
l'évolution de chaque être vivant
suit les lois de la nature
l'évolution humaine présente plutôt certains
anomalies en 1860, théorise Darwin
évolution naturelle mais sur l'homme
cette théorie est démentie par le célèbre
le chaînon manquant est le progrès scientifique
conduisent aujourd'hui à 4 anomalies
de l'évolution humaine mais ils ne savent pas
lui expliquer une réponse
bien qu'incroyable il est donné par les anciens
textes sacrés du monde entier et aucun
de ceux-ci il parle d'évolution naturelle
de l'homme
au contraire, ils citent tous une évolution
piloté
[Musique]
les anciens textes chinois indiens sumériens
Égyptiens et Grecs citent la création
de l'homme comme l'œuvre de plusieurs
des êtres non terrestres qu'ils appellent des dieux
[Musique]
les anciens textes hébreux et chrétiens
ils prétendent que l'homme est le produit d'un
l'ajustement des choses existantes et que
un ou plusieurs dieux ont réalisé
une opération chirurgicale avec anesthésie
prélèvement de viande de suture sur adam pour
obtenir eva
[Musique]
L'islam affirme aussi que l'homme est un
nouvelle créature terrestre est apparue du
rien
créé par un seul dieu la science moderne
établi que la vie sur terre est
apparu il y a 4 milliards d'années et plus tard
grandes extinctions de masse engendrées
les plantes les animaux que nous connaissons
[Musique]
il y a soixante millions d'années
les primates sont nés et il y a 5 millions d'années
le premier mini de l'australopithèque apparaît
[Musique]
son volume cérébral est de 450
centimètres cubes comment mesurent les singes
un mètre et 30 centimètres vit
arbres et alterne de quadrupédie à
un peu et c'est parti
il y a deux millions et demi d'années oui
produit une première anomalie
une espèce d'australopithèque passe de 48
chromosomes à 46 et devient un nouveau
créature
homme habilis
[Musique]
comment a-t-il fait
les chromosomes sont porteurs d'informations
génétique aux cellules mais si elles changent
soudain en nombre
le résultat est une aberration
chromosomique et mort
[Musique]
après cette manipulation génétique est
il a fallu cloner un plus tard
grand nombre de mâles et de femelles
fertile pour permettre la survie
de l'espèce
qui pouvait alors se rendre compte dans
massent ces manipulations génétiques qui
les scientifiques modernes savent à peine
[Musique]
les extraterrestres
le voir le plus ancien des livres indiens
cite 400 000 races humanoïdes existantes
dans la Voie Lactée et parmi eux un
des dizaines sont déjà venus visiter la terre
à plusieurs reprises, l'ésotérisme affirme que
il y a beaucoup d'êtres dans l'univers
semblables aux humains parce que les lois sont
le même partout dans la création
le plus vieux de ces êtres année
la coutume de greffer leur ADN ni la
humanoïdes les différentes planètes dans le but de
obtenir leur union en un seul
conscience
[Musique]
ça peut être celui des mâles et des femelles
les australopithèques ont fait l'objet de
cette coutume et donc génétiquement
inhumains mutés dont la première étape est la
liszt guéri
le fait est que l'homme habilis survit
au changement de structure
chromosomique devenant le premier
son représentant de l'humanité
la taille reste à 130 cm mais son volume
cérébrale passe de 450 à 600 cc c i
ses dents
sa structure osseuse nasale change
voûté mais marche
exclusivement sur pied et fabrication de
cailloux ébréchés pour se défendre contre
prédateurs et démembrer les animaux
il y a un million d'années un homo
habilis quitte l'afrique pour l'europe
le moyen-orient géorgie chine
indonésie comment ils ont fait
à l'époque quelques centaines
des hominidés armés de pierres que tu poses
d'accord avec les grognements et les gestes pour
embarquer pour un voyage
intercontinental à pied ne peut pas
aller si loin et dans tant d'endroits
du monde
en même temps à moins qu'ils ne soient
été amenés comme nos reproducteurs
ils portent leur bétail
camions sur les navires et parfois même dans
avion
une fois arrivés, ils changent
devenir une nouvelle créature lomo
erectus dont la capacité crânienne diminue
soudainement de 600 à 800 50 centimètres
cubique
selon les lois de la nature, il est
une aberration génétique un tel saut
l'évolution a besoin de centaines de
des millions d'années pour le faire à moins que
cette manipulation est effectuée dans
laboratoire
suite plus tard
[Musique]
le fait est que l'homme erectus réussit
apprivoise aussi très bien les vies de feu
sereinement pour un million et demi
ans et s'étend avec succès en asie
en afrique et en europe
[Musique]
l'homo erectus n'a pas besoin de
monnaie
encore un saut incroyable
l'évolution le modifie
Il y a 200 000 ans, les régions d'évolution
accélération du cerveau d'homo
erectus augmente soudainement et
énormément leur efficacité
[Musique]
pourtant, dans le cerveau des animaux, ces
les régions restent stables pendant des centaines
de millions d'années pour obtenir une telle
résultat en si peu de temps
ne sait pas que le laboratoire est le cerveau
de l'homo erectus double presque
allant de 850 à 1450 centimètres cubes
et devient une nouvelle espèce d'homo sapiens
cependant la tête de son fœtus est trop
grand pour sortir des organes de
reproduction pour sauvegarder l'espèce
Humain
la naissance est alors avancée au 9 des 18
mois qu'il faudrait mais là
la mortalité des nourrissons humains est fréquente
[Musique]
la science n'explique pas ce passage
anormal entre homme erectus et homo
sapiens
[Musique]
nous laissons cette tâche aux Sumériens
leurs tablettes il est écrit celle des
des humanoïdes géants venus d'ailleurs je
annonces guerrières après la colonisation
mars et la lune s'installent
la mésopotamie a rejoint et en afrique en
zimbabwe où ils exploitent des mines d'or
[Musique]
besoin de main d'oeuvre pour
les fouilles ont un qui en capture un
dieu féminin moretto combiner
génétiquement son adn avec l'adn non
sait qu'il y a 200 000 ans
toujours selon les Sumériens cette femelle
général homo sapiens une nouvelle espèce
cathédrale capable de comprendre les commandes et les annonces
Obéir
[Musique]
pourtant nu homme sapiens et n'est pas
adapté à tout environnement n'a pas de gros
cheveux et crocs tandis que ses cheveux
ils grandissent continuellement en s'enchevêtrant
partout cela complique la survie
dans la nature mais les homo sapiens sont
de spécialistes dans la fabrication de
les outils se coupent les cheveux
ils socialisent et gesticulent pour se faire
comprendre le crachotement des mots
[Musique]
il y a environ 60 mille ans, un quart
l'anomalie accélère à nouveau l'évolution
Humain
[Musique]
une révolution inconcevable dans
nature dott.sa all'homo sapiens et del
pensée symbolique pour la première fois
dans l'histoire du pays des êtres
ils dépassent les limites du présent
seulement à tous les organismes vivants et
ils extraient des symboles mentaux qu'il y a
conduire à théoriser le futur
l'infini et le transcendant
[Musique]
puisque la pensée symbolique ne
il ne servirait à rien s'il n'exprimait pas
des concepts le larynx et le palais
l'homme en forme parle maintenant
confortablement et bien que sauvage se dispute
d'échanges et de sentiments qu'il est devenu
l'homme notre ancêtre commun
le premier humain le seul être vivant un
s'étudie et s'interroge sur
fonctionnement du monde
[Musique]
cette fois il n'y a pas eu d'extension
cerveau
il y avait un mécanisme génétique qui a fait
il est déverrouillé dans le cerveau humain et il le sait
reformaté en activant la pensée
symbolique
cette très forte accélération donnée à
gènes du développement céphalique
il n'est pas possible qu'en laboratoire avec
l'utilisation du génie génétique
[Musique]
l'homme peuple avec succès le monde
quand il y a 12 000 ans un grand
météorite est tombée sur terre causant
un déluge qui noie tous les êtres
hommes vivants inclus
J'ai vu plus de données sur cette catastrophe
nous prenons les abonnés au pied de la lettre
Sumériens ceux-ci disent que le
anunnaki sont sauvés à bord du leur
piloter des avions et qui est aussi un leader
Annunaki avertit un homme du déluge
génétiquement amélioré fermant le
nom biblique lui conseillant de construire
une arche pour sauvegarder le patrimoine
génétique de sa famille de
Animaux et plantes
quand le déluge se termine ils sont sauvés
seulement quelques humains
se réfugie dans les montagnes et sa famille
fermeture qui se mélangent
repeupler la terre
puis la terre anunnaki et oui
ils partagent le monde avec tout son peuple
habitants
[Musique]
les anunnaki se battent pour
enjeux territoriaux
[Musique]
et comme ils sont très avancés
technologiquement, il n'est pas difficile pour
de capturer les hommes et de les forcer à
travail ou guerre
à cette époque les hommes sont les mêmes
intelligent que font les hommes modernes
l'intérêt et les mystères de la mort et à
amulettes magiques mais bien qu'ils cuisinent le
les aliments sont des sauvages vivants
sans règles et sans morale
[Musique]
en bref, et aussi réciter l'eden un
immense enceinte construite par les Annunaki
entre l'arménie et la mer caspienne
[Musique]
dans ces endroits ils m'ont un ça
animaux domestiques non sauvages
[Musique]
la mutation chromosomique du mouton
le mouflon sauvage du moyen-orient est
le seul animal au monde dont cependant
devient continuellement très utile pour
faire des vêtements chauds en laine
le chien est la domestication du loup
oriental transformé en gardien
obéissant le cheval est là
domestication de la bâche anna orientale
le boeuf est une mutation génétique du bos
Taureau
[Musique]
parmi les légumes le génome de l'épeautre
sauvage se marie incroyablement avec
le génome d'une grande menace ou
comestible et génère du grain
[Musique]
pourtant dans la nature s'il y a fusion
le corps meurt à moins que cela
modification génétique soit
fabriqué en laboratoire
[Musique]
l'eden est devenu un champ d'agriculture
et l'élevage a besoin de travailleurs
ils m'ont un qui ils attrapent alors
toute une tribu d'hommes et les porte
dans l'en-tête
[Musique]
ici les prisonniers sont domestiqués
effectuer un travail servile e
amélioré pour en faire un nouveau
genre d'hommes je à des amis
les amis ne peuvent pas quitter le
eden mais ils y vivent très bien
la nourriture est aussi assurée qu'un
apprentissage culturel et technologique
considérable sans parler de l'absence
de danger hors d'Eden, le monde est
peuplé de bêtes féroces et d'hommes sauvages
pourtant il y a 6 000 ans à des amis
laissez-les descendre le long de la
la mésopotamie s'installe entre les rivières
Les tigres de l'Euphrate ont trouvé le pays de su mar
et grâce aux connaissances acquises en Eden
ils apportent aux indigènes du jour au lendemain
une civilisation fonctionnelle prête est beaucoup
Avancée
[Musique]
les Sumériens inventent l'écriture
représentant des expressions phonétiques
du mot avec des caractères cunéiformes
ils inventent l'école pour l'éducation et
le droit de punir l'injustice
effectuer des calculs compliqués dans
l'ingénierie et sont les premiers à utiliser
les nombres se montrant capables de résoudre
des équations algébriques du tiers
diplôme en astronomie savoir tout
planètes de notre système solaire
y compris uranus neptune et pluton qui
ils ont été découverts il y a seulement 100 ans je
Les Sumériens inventent aussi le calendrier
divisant la journée en 24 heures et l'heure en
60 minutes
[Musique]
ainsi apparaît la civilisation sumérienne
tout à coup où il n'y avait plus que
cabanes et l'histoire du monde commence là
son aventure aventure dont pas
nous savons que les 5 mille dernières années mais
qui sait ce qui s'est passé entre-temps
puisque l'espèce homo existe depuis aussi longtemps que 2
et un demi-million d'années
[Musique]